it's girl scout cookie season in las
vegas which means there'll be hundreds
of young ladies out and about selling
these decadent treats thank you to girl
scouts of southern nevada for sponsoring
this segment and here to tell us more is
aubrey from troop 671 we've got amy here
as well with the girl scouts of southern
nevada and also down is just taylor down
here yes yes how are you welcome you
three it's great to have you here so
first off how can we buy these delicious
cookies right right so the girls have
been doing pre-sale since january 10th
the past four or five weeks cookies just
arrived here in town saturday and the
booth sales opened up yesterday so the
best way to get girl scout cookies right
now is go out to the booths and buy them
up they're all over the valley how can
people pay for these cookies because a
lot of times i don't have cash you're
selling the cookies i got no cash what
can i do
right well if you don't have cash you
can always pay with square which is
debit or credit
venmo
you take it all right you do veto as
well yes so there's no excuse for not to
buy girl scout cookies there's many
different ways that you take them let's
talk about the cookies because do you
have a new one this year we do actually
we have the adventure fulls right there
yeah tell me about this so this is this
one right here tell me about it what's
in this one
the adventure full is a brownie
based cookie with a caramel
toffee like on the top with a drizzle of
chocolate sea salt now as i'm trying
this cookie
can i order cookies online and send them
the family back east how does that work
yeah you want to talk about that aubry
well you can order the cookies online
and you can ship them to out of state
people and like um
just you have to
select the shipping obviously so and you
need to know a girl scout to order
online they each have their own sales
page so ask around if you're like i've
got a kid that's away at college but i'm
going to get my kids some girl scouts
find yourself a girl scout go online
order and then you'll need to ship them
out yeah what do you like best about
being a girl scout
what i like best about being a girl
scout is just being able to know that we
are giving girls a chance to know that
they can grow up in a community where
they can also be as strong
as a guy or uh knowing that they can
have a strong job like a president or
teaching them
management ethics and business skills i
love it go on preach on i love hearing
them
now how do you become someone's watching
right now and they want to get involved
how do you become a member yeah that's a
great question because right now we know
that girls need girl scouts right the
last two years we haven't had a lot of
social structure a lot of opportunities
to interact but girl scouts for 110
years has been the place where girls can
go and find community and find that
sense of connection and work on
community projects so we're looking for
girls right now but more importantly
we're looking for troop leaders and this
sounds scary to a lot of people but it's
really not there's training we tell you
what to do it's super fun it's like an
hour a week come be a troop leader with
us get your girls involved just go to
girl scouts nb.org click the join button
we will reach out and get you going
fantastic and by the way the cookie was
amazing thank you so much ladies for
joining us and thank you to girl scouts
of southern nevada for sponsoring this
segment you can buy cookies now through
march 6. you can call 702-385-3677
jillian over to you jc has some serious
self-control he only ate one cookie i
always eat the whole box